so we're done with the GOP health care
bill now here's the deal this is a
disaster I won't be I won't tell you
anything else this is a disaster it's
not good it doesn't look good for
Republicans it certainly doesn't look
good for having a functional government
on any level now
the left is taking this opportunity as
it deals with health care to try and
push their solution which of course is a
single-payer plan a universal health
care plan The Young Turks enter Young
Turks he always transitioning they
always do them they released a video
today with the title now this is
important because it's the title of the
video it says universal health care has
been working great in Germany for a long
caps time let's get to what they say the
story of universal health care begins in
Prussia in the late 19th century with we
have an image room this is Otto von
Bismarck and he not only proposed the
first modern welfare state but also in
1883 proposed the sickness insurance law
which really be precursor to modern
universal health care and it's actually
known as the Bismarck plan in many
European countries talk about quality
control that nobody just I own your
shirt he looks good like Tony Hawk had
sex with it [ __ ] Tony Hawk okay so
he's talking about that how do by the
way not only ad hominem but ad hominem
in addendum to substance can be a lot of
fun so the biz markie talked about the
first welfare state it's a scam like the
wealth the welfare state is almost
invariably a scam it is a Ponzi scheme
I'm a Rick Perry cotton is so much got
so much flak for saying social care he
was a Ponzi scheme in Bismarck ok the
retirement age for their welfare
security net was set at 70 average life
expectancy at that time was 42 some
would say that's brilliant what's funny
is actually mirrors a lot of you know
United States Social Security think it
was set that the average life expectancy
was 68 it was set at 65 and there were
either three workers per retiree or
three retirees per worker but now it's
something like 16 retirees per worker so
invariably you have to add more people
more people paying in or you simply have
to change the math for it to work that
is the definition of a Ponzi scheme
according to the SEC the only reason
it's not considered a Ponzi scheme is
because these are the same people who
write the rules from the SEC so but not
a weed
I think in Bismark about 10% of people
there's your universal health care
coverage 10% of people who are covered
so it wasn't necessarily successful but
let's get to more of their arguments as
to why it's been working in Germany
specifically for a long time I've heard
this I don't there's no any evidences
but I've heard from my physician friends
at around 1900 was around the break the
point where you if you went to see a
doctor you were had a better chance of
the doctor healing you than making you
worse
what happened around 1900 not the
entirety human of history for some
reason at 19 it is nothing nothing
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing
Oh vaccines and x-rays it was a Second
Industrial Revolution dumbass again this
was free enterprise and capitalism and
technology benefiting mankind through
the modern marvels of medicine something
which of course is stifled under a
socialized system if you actually look
at medical research was being conducted
okay so the Young Turks here's a prop I
wish we had more clips there's nothing
in there about Germany completely
completely when used you title a video
it's been working in Germany for a long
time I think clickbait as I expect a
video about universal health care in
Germany yeah and and and then there
isn't one there so let's address the
arguments because a lot of people just
see the clickbait title and say hey it's
been working inject we've had this we've
had people on the show liberals come up
with titles and we're going on a second
hat how you substantiate that we just so
happen to have spend computer our intern
from Germany so and the reason this is
important is because they've pivoted it
used to be Canada all the time and now
they're going to Germany kind of like
when Bernie Sanders talked about
Venezuela used examples for socialism
and then he said uh it's not really
Denmark said we're not socialists
anymore stop calling a socialist and I
go uh Sweden and there's rape and they
go back to Germany like shoot we're just
here so these are things that you don't
know about Germany everyone in Germany
has to pay fourteen point six percent of
their salary for health care each day
and you can only opt-out if you make
over forty eight hundred euros per month
think about that for a second if you're
making fifty sixty thousand euros a year
that could be over seventy five hundred
euros at the end of the year which by
the way if you look at American plans
privatized plans for an individual young
healthy birth that would be way higher
than most people who pay yes but let's
assume you're fine because you don't
want personal responsibility you no
choice intimidate
so you just want the government to take
care of it what are the numbers look
like alright not get here let's bring up
this next number here Germany has the
fourth highest health expenses in the
world and the compulsory individual fees
but a state or private carry on at a
rate rising faster than inflation now I
know that you'll say well active well we
have some of the biggest health care
cost in the role and I'm not going to
I'm not going to argue that the United
States the current system is not working
that's because we have an ungodly
marriage between government and private
insurance and lobbyist groups and
special interest groups and kind of
bordering on going to a public option
but we didn't really get it and so costs
of skyrocket I just like when you look
at the the industry for student loans
this is a cottage industry that involves
an overly intrusive government it
doesn't work right now our costs are
high I'll be the first to acknowledge
that but the solution is not to go to a
system that yields lower quality worse
results lower survival rates add
increased costs certainly if you apply
to the United States when it has you
know 10 times a population 20 times the
population of some of these countries
life expectancy how do you substantiate
the how is it higher quality of care
life expectancy rates are much higher
with mortal diseases here in the United
States as a matter of fact depending on
the cancer it can be up to twice as much
in the United States then in Germany it
and here's here's something else even if
none of these numbers we have more of
these numbers we'll have them available
you can look at the resources even if
none of these numbers were true it still
doesn't take into account that Germany
Sweden Denmark they don't have to foot
the bill for the security of the entire
free industrialized world to begin with
when I lived in Canada and there we well
you know the United States doesn't have
this we can do this socially we can do
this well for crime I'm going yeah well
yeah but that's because the only reason
that you aren't being conquered by
anyone who feels like if at that given
moment in time is because the United
States love Canada but you have a crappy
health care system that's subsidized by
tax dollars because it doesn't go to
creating a military let's break this
down so the solution here from the left
was to force everyone to buy private
health insurance okay
now force insurance companies to accept
everyone now again this is where the
filter through which you see the world
matters because if you go home saying
there all these people who are uninsured
here's go that's me why were the
uninsured
there's a significant amount of people
who were young who didn't want to be
insured there was a significant amount
of people who had serious pre-existing
conditions who never purchased insurance
until they had some kind of catastrophe
hit them so it's not just people
couldn't afford
health care it wasn't just the generic
middle-class American worker couldn't
afford a basic health that's just not
reality
but if you look through the lens of
entitlement that's how you did so let's
force everyone to buy insurance okay put
all those people in there now force
insurance companies to accept everyone
now including the highest risk highest
highest cost applicants in their risk
pool
now the solution because costs are out
of control this is what you see they
actually talk about this in the video
and I had people talk on Twitter before
we go to a prior go to a universal
health care plan a public option we need
to force insurance companies to set
price maximums we need to enforce rules
now that insurance companies can't
charge more to stay afloat which they
need now when they're bringing in all
kinds of people who live on a diet of of
soda and fried Snickers and come in
because they didn't get insurance until
they have two legs removed because of
their diabetes and they watched a
Wilford Brimley commercial said I think
I have that so now I want to tell the
insurance companies that person walks in
your door millions of them and you can't
charge them more listen the textbooks
definitions capitalism economics and
what's going to happen insurance
companies won't be able to sit in and so
they'll close their doors which of
course is what the left wants they want
to see all insurance companies closed
their doors they want a public option
and they want the public option to be
the only option and that brings us to a
single-payer system this is the solution
that they have and this is why when you
look at Amy this is where the
Republicans cannot concede ground
because this is the ultimate goal the
left you see it with the first drafting
of the American health care bill of the
Affordable Care Act from Barack Obama
you see it with the public option you
see it with their statements regarding
the public option of the public option
we could just continually flood it with
federal tax dollars and no private
insurance company can compete until it's
the only option from single-payer health
care that has always been their goals so
we cannot go any further along the trail
they want insurance companies to close
the door so that that's what they can
have but I'm sure that the mr. producer
from The Young Turks was going to get to
that many urban US workers gained access
to what's called sickness insurance yeah
they've got the wrong image there but
we'll get through it I've so the IRS tax
changes but so but the question what's
interesting to me is that nobody seems
to know why employer-based health care
plans
you know what that is but the the
workers okay okay but the problem is
finish decision but he pulled the Social
Security health care elements so they
were able to do that and Syria I don't
know what that is but universal health
care see this is my old TV they say the
internet hasn't a right it's just low
quality don't lump us in with that guy
that guy is a dinosaur in new media and
he still hasn't learned to read prompter
but I mean he still haven't learned to
use a hairbrush hey if you liked this
video subscribe by clicking the button
that says subscribe if you're not aware
of it now there's no way you're learning
the Internet at this point I'm not going
to help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit com / mug club members
of your student military or veteran
internet promo code it's less than six
dollars a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand
etched mug oh I just when I feel it I
got a chill like on the inside